this is gonna sound a little
bizarre
because not everybody is is fortunate to
have this experience
but
live life
as if
life is long
and that sounds weird because a lot of
people say like life is short do it up
uh
but then you have kids and you have a
spouse and or not your jobs or your
bills
and you go like okay well maybe this is
this is life like let me let me
enjoy it if you i think sometimes you
know when i was when i was in my teens
and 20s
i kind of did the life is short like do
it up
um
and then
in hindsight now i'm realizing that my
favorite experiences
are when i lived life like life is long
like let every let relationships grow
let
uh yourself grow um
and don't be so hard on yourself is one
thing don't be so hard on yourself yeah
yeah i'm so hard on myself that's the
worst it's like give yourself a working
break
yeah you know
that's that's that's the way i'm wired i
don't want to let people
yeah man yeah you know and you've got a
lot to like you get you don't want your
wife down your kids down your crew down
your friend like you've got a lot going
on so it's it's easy to go there and you
gotta try not to go there
you